SWEG
67 wise no
schigorin so the
exchange variant let's see how it was
decide which structure he
chooses
yes the
endgame variant
here
of course I don't know my way around here either, I have to say
but
I always found it hard to believe that
that's completely okay  for
black but of course it has
often been used by strong
players,
yes, all in all it actually looks
okay for black. I would
think I certainly didn't get
much out of it, if anything at all,
probably
nothing at all. Well, what about the Z H6?
hold on to the pawn to nail it I
'll do that
sometimes, of course,
the pawn could also become a weakness, namely me
exactly in the minor pieces
game maybe maybe you can
do G4 straight away
oh no mouselip I of course want to hit E6
God
check of course very
annoying
has a whole lot more speed  It's just a completely
different
story
Check
Checkmate Yes, sometimes I have to take another
look. Sometimes there's an
unexpected
checkmate. Yes, well, actually that was the game
that I was always supposed to miss, but well, I was
lucky